bon sang ne saurait mentir vous
connaissez la formule voici maintenant
le dernier spectacle du petit fils de
charlie chaplin entre le mime le théâtre
et la danse ils s'appellent james
thierrée et vous allez le voir il ya
comme un air de famille sophie jouve
didier d'armes entre rêve et cauchemar à
la frontière de deux mondes
c'est là que nous entraîne james
thierrée on jongle avec le temps on
lutte avec les objets tous les
sortilèges dans ce monde chimérique
on croise même des portraits rebelles et
des fantômes délurée tout inclus
où j'ai trouvé sa main dans l'enfance
dans les rêves qu'on fait dans les
désirs inassouvis dans ces choses qu'on
voudrait tellement atteindre et qu'on a
pas un peu au cinéma mais qu'on peut
atteindre aussi sur un plateau et même
si la ressemblance est troublante
il n'a jamais utilisé le nom de son
grand père shapping danse cirque mime
tirs et a su créer son propre univers
loufoque et poétique
sa symphonie du hanneton échappe à tout
classement
un combat fantastique avec des
casseroles pour armand un bestiaire
improbable sorties de l'inconscient
dans ce paradis les métamorphoses les
spectateurs toutes générations
confondues s'envole sur un petit nuage